right there oh my
goodness oh my little s oh wow you
remember that yeah it's true I just said
that statement
yesterday wow I've never seen anything
like this before this is awesome
this these were the good old days
hi yeah now I'm all Hur and beat
up oh my
goodness this is like a like a photo yba
kind of sort of like awesome just a
collection of portraits from my project
that's this you rock Mark well at least
it's like memorable like I'll forever
be I'll forever be known immortalized
yeah I guess known as the woman who said
that I've been raped so many times that
it's become
acceptable it had it did until that one
that incident where when I got hurt a
couple weeks later then that's when it
was not okay I realized it was so not
okay mhm takes time sometimes yeah you
they say you know women women they're
being beaten or abused by their Partners
I think it on average it takes like
seven attempt seven or eight uh tries
for them to get away oh yeah sheesh if
they're lucky I mean if they can get
away you know some girls don't make it
you know wow well thank you
for no for being part of this project no
thank you Mark because I've met girls
that said have told me like you know wow
thank you they've thanked me for just
being open and honest
about up about you know my situation and
uh then I know that you know I I I I
made my I did my my carbon footprint I
did my part I put it out there I I open
and honest
and I share my story which I always
wanted to do and it's going to help
somebody because I've met girls that
said told me thank you you know I have
friends that I've met that are like wow
you really did that like you're you're
so brave and I'm like I never thought of
was being brave I just wanted people to
know what's going on you know just want
to share that share that story because a
lot of people don't they're honest they
they popped this life it's glamorous and
glorious you know look what happened in
past two three years to me you
know but it's a rough lifestyle isn't it
it's one of the roughest I know one of
the I think they say it's oldest
profession and it's the roughest
profession as well you
know
Brave I don't know if it's bravado
but you know I thank the Lord that you
I'm still here you know I think the Lord
that people care you're a Survivor yeah
I that's what I am I'm a Survivor a lot
of people have not made it we you know
that a lot of people haven't made it and
there in the F there's a lot of people
that won't make it you know Bonafide a
whole bunch of them there a lot and in
the future the ones that are to come you
know but then you have people like me
Survivor I Will
Survive yeah thank you Mark for me
seeing thank you thank you you're
awesome thank you for that and all your
help oh yeah anytime I'm here help
anybody all right thank you you're
amazing thank oh that's
awesome